foreign
[Music]
there are scary things we don't
understand
our minds try to
fill in the blanks
Sometimes the best thing to do is to
face it
so this light is going to be completely
solid like it is right now
then gradually it's going to start
flashing until it's totally dark
so you can see that there's nothing to
be afraid of
okay
that's not so scary is it
just you you sister and me
[Music]
it's not real
okay
it's all just in your head
[Music]
foreign
I'm serious Sawyer I need to be alone
you're both having these manifestations
[Music]
not paying attention
[Applause]
dad you have to listen to me okay
I'm listening
sweetheart let me handle
[Music]
are you ready we're ready to forget the
further once and for all
[Music]
my brain just been foggy past few years
all I ever wanted was to be a good dad
Dalton
um
[Music]
did you ever try and get help I'm just
trying to push through
[Music]
Dalton to college you still have a few
weeks before your students show up right
just an idea to reconnect I know it's
been tough with you too
[Music]
the balance of light and dark is what we
are
we're at you're an art school I take it
yeah you yeah you're here too yeah
yeah draw an experience that defines you
when I was 10.
it's in a coma
remember being sick
deep into your memory
and let's see what life can find
I'm seeing crazy stuff
I think these drawings could be Clues
from my past
there's so much you don't know when I
was too scared to tell you the truth our
family has been keeping secrets they
suppressed our memories but I can still
feel something following us there's only
one way to find out
thank you
I feel like I'm getting closer to
something
if something's getting closer to me
[Applause]
when you awaken the Dead
the further you travel the riskier your
journey will become
welcome
I am
black we will make a very good assistant
no he's evil we will protect you you
have the word of the most trusted
institution on Earth the Catholic Church
[Music]
friend here your sole purpose in life is
to serve me now let's see
I just want a normal life again
God bless you Mr Renfield oh God bless
you nuns you're a hero Robert Montague
Renfield
let me explain I work for Dracula Count
Dracula
it's the real Dracula some call me the
dark one other is the Lord of death so
you ring and people to eat well I do
other stuff like what washes cake no the
Cape is dry clean only strictly yeah I
will wear this it's fly yeah
I'm gonna think he's such a bad guy but
you're never really gonna be free until
you face him I will no longer tolerate
abuse
you deserve only suffering I will
unleash in all that does everyone you
care about will suffer because you
betrayed me we have to stop him Before
Sunset
[Music]
foreign
you know when something crazy happens
and someone's like it's okay I've seen
way worse everything I saw you do today
is gonna be my way worse it's my least
favorite part of the job
[Music]
the Demeter
on Charter from Romanian to London
shipping private crates
content unknown
out at Sea with no land in sight
dress like a learned man University of
Cambridge and on my way around the boat
our Charter has agreed to pay upon us
for timely arrival number
let me show you the ship this here is
huckleberry
we don't come with like this to give the
use clear
[Applause]
something right about the animals
for the livestock this looks like a bite
search the ship everywhere
evil isn't bored
[Music]
powerful evil
in night it rings our blood he's just
here
we call him Dracula
he's coming
you see the size of that Bloody things
[Music]
he is on this ship which means that we
will never leave it the devil is real
may God have mercy on us all
no matter how busy you ever got you
always found time for me
I can't believe I'm never gonna speak
when I was just a little girl
I asked my mother what is this Danny
[Music]
foreign
don't let it take my babies
[Music]
Terror through total chaos
[__]
[Music]
please
oh yeah yeah you know how to like kids
mom Mommy's with the maggots now
okay
what will be will be
any
meaning
have you seen the group chat I'm doing
it again tonight
huh
no please what's my mom's Remembrance
Day I just want to forget about it huh
[Applause]
I'll do it
cannot go for more than 90 seconds am I
clear what happens after 90 seconds
don't want to stay
like the candle to open the door
blow it out to close it
put your hand on it
now say
talk to me
[Music]
what does the hand feel like
it felt amazing I can't see and feel
everything on the other side
so my mom she was trying to reach out
here
still been seeing stuff you've been
saying stuff
what if we opened the door but we didn't
shut it
they're
never gonna stop
I like you
[Music]
Ella when are you and Aiden gonna have
kids Ella doesn't want kids
why don't you want kids well you want
kids the family is everything I have a
family don't worry your clock will kick
out I mean what do you do all day
without kids
I've been through this a million times
and I'm happy with or without kids I
really wish I even leave them there's a
couple of Empty Chairs at the table Dad
can we not
don't want
I never have I actually don't have a
clock all women have a biological clock
maybe yours is just
broken
new biotech firm doing a clinical trial
this month can get you in
[Music]
it is the singular evolutionary goal of
a species to procreate that is our
purpose we administer a newly engineered
synthetic hormone pair that with
cognitive behavioral therapy and the
option of an implant
deep breath
I might be a tough case you're not a
case to me Ella you're a human being and
the best kind too what kind is that a
woman
you want kids today we'll be learning to
perform maintenance your family is
everything on a working clock to reset
the Cog I am out of time
[Music]
out of time working clock
shut up
[Music]
welcome home
I know this place isn't as warm as I'd
hoped
but I'm going to light a vanilla candle
and it's going to be a game changer
we're out
this Mansion is unhinged she needs all
the help she can get you want to be a
hero
pass two thousand dollars what's the
address
[Music]
little help
you
[Music]
this house has a way of Playing Tricks
on you
[Music]
oh my God is anybody else seeing this
yeah I'm seeing it
be careful
death lurks around every corner
other more powerful entities may come
through not on our watch what are you
gonna do
seriously yeah they're already dead
you're gonna be deader okay
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[__] probably runs on racism
used to play and she dies
I think we have to play the game
in your predicament the black character
is always the first to die I will spare
your lives if you sacrifice the person
you deem the blackest to blackest nobody
used to judge anybody in here you have
two minutes to decide Friday
[Music]
I voted for Trump what
twice
up we need a plan I'm saying don't you
dare don't say this don't see you we
have to split up
[Applause]
let's run out it's time to die
[Music]
there's a crazy person oh yeah you got
Rosa Parks on your shirt right we should
be sitting down right now I mean
that's exactly what she did
made you look
what made you look
what black women gotta save everyone
else
yo stop playing
I got a gun
that's two DMX what are you doing
[Music]
we'll take it congratulations
foreign
[Music]
welcome to the neighborhood I brought
you something it's a necklace it's very
pretty who gives a stranger something
when I expected something in return Mike
this is just some sweet old lady
thank you
Mike
your house I don't like it
scared it's okay
I love you
[Music]
thank you
I just arrived and it's amazing I can't
believe they let us keep all the
furniture I'm having the girls over
later so I'll see you tomorrow
I still can't tell if this house is
creepy or clean it's Cape Cod every
place is birth creepy and quit I'm
really glad you guys are here Amen to
that
yeah my parents bought me this great
place because they think I'll live here
forever and they'll see me more often
the Tufts were mad all the tubs are dead
and gone and it's my place now I can't
just abide by the fact that she bought
the tough house she has to regret coming
back here
they took our phone
[Music]
I told her what would happen if she came
back
[Music]
ouch
you're the goats
you got a problem here guy
[Music]
foreign
I had this Secret
there's a Darkness inside of me
it followed me here
and it's Gonna Keep Coming For Us
we share a certain history
isn't like any other
place
shrine
we execute him
hello let's play a game you know you're
like the 10th guy to try this right it
never works out for the [__] and the
mask
Maybe
I'm something
different
that's why I'm gonna shoot you in the
[__] head
foreign
so let's finish this
surprise
you know you're the first person I ever
shown this place to why am I so special
because soon we'll be Christopher you
know you love them
should be close now we're not going to
fight them we will poo piglet Eeyore we
were friends for many years and they're
out there
Christopher we need to leave now I
really need to find out what's happening
okay
foreign
[Music]
these three friends why are you doing
this please I would have never left
father Gabriella amort
[Music]
on the night of June 4th
you performed an exorcism
that was not an exorcism
the majority of cases do not require an
exorcism
98 I'd recommend and buy him to doctors
and psychiatrists
the other two percent
I call it
evil
we have more questions for you father
Mort
you have a problem with me you talk to
my boss
they Pope there's a case that needs your
attention
bring me the priest I'm here to help
Julia
wrong right
they cautioned their secrets buried
there
about the concealer
Church escort against this demon before
the Vatican covered it up we need to
find out why
you've been playing you took the Bates
whatever you do you only do because God
allows him
imagine what could happen if the devil
possessed the soul of the Pope's
Exorcist who will defend
my faith
does not require defense
[Music]
I know
Island
[Music]
you hold it down Abigail you know better
than Adventure be on the path at night
you should never come here
we'll be safe in the valley
oh
[__]
where you think you're going
foreign
they sent me out to find you where's my
family
they can lead the Lord right to us
Sadler and bring her back
honey
[Music]
thank you